there's a brand new pullout from gallup
and it is not spelling good news for u.s
institutions but there's some good news
in there as well if we take a look we
can see that u.s institution confidence
has been dropping rapidly and now is
sitting near all-time lows at the same
exact time small businesses there is
still an immense amount of confidence
that the american population has in
those small business leaders the
military the police and the medical
system also coming in with high degrees
of confidence by the american public
but if we go all the way to the bottom
the criminal justice system big business
television news and congress all hitting
near all-time lows in consumer
confidence from the american population
if we take a look at this year's polls
it marks new lows in confidence for all
three branches of the federal government
the supreme court at 25 percent the
presidency at 23 and congress coming in
last on the list
five other institutions are at their
lowest points and at least three decades
of measurement including church
newspapers the criminal justice system
big business and the police and of
course confidence in large tech
companies is also at a low point 26
but has only been measured for the past
three years
one thing that's interesting with these
gallup polls if we go all the way back
to the late 70s early 80s there was a
high degree of confidence from u.s
adults in many of these institutions but
as you can see over the couple of
decades since then we have seen a
decreasing consistent fall
in the confidence of major u.s
institutions
coming in this year at an all-time low
americans confidence in institutions has
been lacking for most of the past 15
years but their trust in key
institutions has hit a new low this year
most of the institutions gallop tracks
are at historic lows and average
confidence across all institutions is
now four points lower than the prior low
what's fascinating about these results
is that if you walked out on the street
and you asked people do you have more or
less confidence in these institutions
you would expect them to say less
confidence but small businesses which
make up about 50 percent of jobs in
america
quite literally the backbone of the
american economy
the american population still has lots
of confidence in them
still understands the value they provide
and it's willing to stand behind those
small business entrepreneurs
institutions may be getting less and
less popular and maybe eliciting less
confidence but small businesses are
hanging in there and that's because
average citizens who risk their capital
their time and their energy to build
these small businesses they've got skin
in the game
and the gallup poll is showing the
american people appreciate that hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time